president's oldest daughter Ivanka Trump
is getting comfortable in the West Wing
joining her husband Jared Kushner she
recently began working in an
unprecedented role as assistant to the
president
cushions you know as a senior advisor
Jan Crawford is in the green room with
the unique roles that the president's
family plays in his administration Jan
good morning - good morning Yale so here
in the green room right behind me are
the stairs that lead to the president's
residence a private residence with those
appointments he's sending a clear
message that he's keeping it in the
family
but he's not the first president to do
that throughout history dozens of
children and their spouses have had
prominent roles in the White House I am
rather unfamiliar with this role as well
as it is quite new to me new but not
really unfamiliar on a campaign trail
the entire family supported Donald Trump
now as sons Don Jr and Eric run the
private business daughter Ivanka and her
husband Jared Kushner are taking on
public service both have met with
several foreign dignitaries and Kushner
visited Iraq before the Secretary of
State or national security adviser his
son-in-law Jared Kushner a senior
adviser is arguably the most powerful
person in the White House with a huge
portfolio just 102 days in Kushner has
been tasked with criminal justice reform
tackling the opioid crisis middle-east
diplomacy and cyber security the unique
familial power is having an impact on
the West we you know it can be very
dangerous I think for other advisors to
fight with them we saw that a few weeks
ago where Steve Bannon the chief
strategist got into a real ideological
debate with Jared Kushner and it did not
end that well for Steve Bannon this is
not only normal it's inevitable
historian and author Doug wheat when
when people see the president bringing
in his daughter and his son-in-law of
such pivotal roles in the White House I
mean that might be surprising to a lot
of people but if you look at history
should that be surprising no it is not
surprising hit it it happens over and
over and over throughout history
presidents eventually come to lean on
the people who are the most loyal it
ceases to become competence and quickly
becomes who can I trust
Ivanka has said she gives her honest
piñon even when it may be hard to hear I
speak up frequently and my father agrees
with me on so many issues and where he
doesn't he knows where I stand now the
first lady and their son Baron will move
here later this summer when Baron
finishes the school year and that will
mean that the only time this white house
has been completely without a
presidential spouse was more than 150
years ago during James view canons
presidency and that's because he wasn't
married
Nora really fascinating Jim thank you so
much